und es schließt sich wie jetzt eben auch
dann noch der Einzelplan für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung an und wir sehen auch schon
die zuständige Ministerin Svenja Schulze
hier auf der Regierungsbank also auch
hier gab es in den ja und immerhin 18
stündigen Bereinigungssitzung des
Haushaltsausschusses in letzter Minute
noch einige Änderung was den
entwicklungsetat anbelangt nämlich eine
Milliarde mehr gab es im Vergleich zum
Regierungsentwurf das Geld soll speziell
für humanitäre Hilfe Wiederaufbau oder
den Kampf auch gegen Hunger genutzt
werden allerdings selbst mit dieser
extra Milliarde steht für das
Entwicklungsministerium weniger Geld zur
Verfügung als in diesem Jahr
und Kollegen meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
vorletzte Woche fand die
Bereinigungssitzung statt übermorgen
wird voraussichtlich die Ampel den
Bundeshaushalt für das nächste Jahr
beschließen soweit so gut aber
beschließt denn die Ampel nach einer
historisch langen Bereinigungssitzung
auch einen historisch guten Haushalt
nein das glaube ich nicht
angesichts der Vielzahl von
Herausforderungen die natürlich Ukraine
Krieg und
ernährungskatastrophe war der
Regierungsentwurf zum BMZ eine einzige
Katastrophe ein abwuchs alles in allem
von 17 Prozent
wieder hat sich gezeigt dass das BMZ und
Ministerin Schulze schlecht verhandelt
haben immerhin und das rettet diesen
Etat hat die Ampel kurz vor knapp in der
Bereinigungssitzung noch eine dringend
benötigte Milliarde und top gesetzt das
ist gut aber das ist nicht so gut wie es
klingt aus der globalen Krisenvorsorge
von 5 Milliarden im Einzelplan 60 hatte
das Auswärtige Amt einen Mehrbedarf von
1,5 Milliarden beantragt das BMZ 3,3
Milliarden am Ende des Tages bekommen
beide Häuser eine Milliarde
jeweils dabei ist der Etat des
Auswärtigen Amtes ungefähr nur halb so
groß wie der des BMZ merken Sie was
das zeigt leider den Stellenwert den das
BMZ in der Koalition beim Kanzler und
beim Finanzminister genießt allen
Beteuerungen zum Trotz
in den Beratungen hat die
Bundesregierung auch Leiter wieder eine
ungute Rolle gespielt wir alle kennen
das Spiel das Spiel ist alt aber es ist
jedes Mal lästig die Regierung hat genau
im Regierungsentwurf in den Titeln
gekürzt von denen sie genau weiß dass
die Haushälter der Koalition das gar
nicht zu stehen lassen können Sie kürzt
in den Titeln in denen ganz
offensichtlich es nicht verantwortbar
ist das ist unredlich das ist unseriös
und es ist wie ich finde auch einfach
überflüssige
zugleich aber ist die Ampel großartig im
Geld ausgeben jeder Koalitionspartner
bekommt einfach das was er möchte die
Ampel weigert sich ganz offensichtlich
den Haushalt zu konsolidieren sie kann
oder will die Kraft nicht dazu
aufbringen bestimmte Aufgaben zu
priorisieren und zwangsläufig dann
andere Aufgaben zu posterisieren das ist
ambitionslos und einfach nur traurig mit
Blick auf die nächste Generation
aber unsere ehrlich will ich sein es
gibt auch Positives zu vermelden so
konnte sich die armbe dazu durchringen
die Mittel für Unido die UN-Organisation
für industrielle Entwicklung zu stärken
deren general Direktor ist ja
bekanntlich unser ehemaliger Minister im
BMZ Gerd Müller ob diese Tatsache der
Grund dafür war ihm im letzten Haushalt
die Unterstützung zu verweigern obwohl
er der einzige deutsche an der Spitze
einer UN-Organisation ist das weiß ich
schlicht und ergreifend nicht
jedenfalls hat er sich schon seit seinem
Amtsantritt eines zum Ziel gesetzt den
chinesischen Einfluss in dieser
Organisation zurückzudrängen und ich
finde liebe Kollegen und Kollegen das
ist doch aller Unterstützung wert
lassen Sie mich noch auf die
berichterstatterreise der
berichterstatterinnen und
Berichterstatter für den Einzelplan 23
von Ende Oktober zu sprechen kommen wir
sind gemeinsam in die Republik Moldau
und in die Ukraine gereist die Gespräche
die wir in Chisinau und in Lemberg
geführt haben die erlaubt mir jetzt mal
für alle Kollegen die dabei waren zu
sprechen haben wohl niemand von uns kalt
gelassen
die Republik Moldau hat die in Europa
höchste flüchtlingsquote nunmehr eine
Inflation von 35 Prozent und seit Anfang
des Jahres haben sich die Gaspreise Vers
7facht seit gut einem Jahr regiert dort
die erste proeuropäische Regierung seit
der Unabhängigkeit 1991 und das mit
absoluter Mehrheit
und genau seit einem guten Jahr plant
Moskau den Umsturz in der Republik
Moldau und das dürfen wir als Europäer
nicht zulassen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ganz besonders beeindruckend aber auch
bedrückend war dann unser Besuch im
westukrainischen Lemberg während unseres
Aufenthalts gab es allein viermal
Luftalarm und ich habe dort eine absolut
faszinierende Beobachtung gemacht ich
hatte das Gefühl dass mit jedem
Luftalarm die Entschlossenheit der
Ukrainerinnen
diesen Krieg gegen Putin zu gewinnen
wächst
und anschließend sprachen wir mit dem
Bürgermeister Lembergs er berichtete uns
über die gezielten russischen
Luftangriffe auf die zivile
Infrastruktur und die daraus
resultierenden Energieprobleme er
berichtete uns zudem vom Aufbau einer
prothesenwerkstatt in der Prothesen für
die Leiter viel zu zahlreichen
Kriegsverletzten hergestellt werden
sollen und das fand ich auch ein ganz
tollen Vorgang noch vor Ort einigten wir
uns als Berichterstatter über
fraktionell darauf den Aufbau der
prothesen-generatoren für die Region
Lemberg zu unterstützen für insgesamt 22
Millionen Euro und diese
diese Entscheidung die war ein direktes
Ergebnis unserer Gespräche vor Ort und
die ehrliche Freude und Dankbarkeit die
uns nach diesem Beschluss aus Lemberg
erreicht haben die haben mich nicht nur
sehr gefreut sondern sie haben mich auch
sehr berührt und das ist ein gutes
Beispiel dafür wie das oft abstrakte tun
von uns Haushältern manchmal auch eine
schnelle und konkrete Hilfe vor Ort
bedeuten kann
ich bedanke mich beim BMZ und bei meinen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
mitberichterstattern für die gute und
konstruktive Zusammenarbeit herzlichen
Dank
die Delegation des Haushaltsausschusses
die hier kassenkörper angesprochen hat
war also Ende Oktober in der Republik
Moldau und in der Ukraine und
zusätzliche Hilfen deutsche Hilfen in
Höhe von
32,3 Millionen Euro für die Republik
Moldau hatte Anna Lena baerbock zugesagt
auch aus dem BMZ Etat kommen davon 28,7
Millionen Bettina Hagedorn die jetzt
spricht war auch Teil dieser Delegation
übrigens bei unserer gemeinsamen Reise
nach Moldau und in die Ukraine und nach
Polen und ich möchte mich vorhin über
unsere delegationsleiterin Claudia
Raffelhüschen bedanken mit der wir
zusammengefahren sind fünf Abgeordnete
von fünf demokratischen Parteien der
Viktor Perli war ja auch dabei und es
ist ein gutes Zeichen wir waren der
erste Ausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages der als Ausschuss in der
Ukraine war das ist von den
Bürgermeister Herren es war ja nicht nur
der Bürgermeister von Lemberg der uns in
seinem Rathaus empfangen hat sondern er
war ja noch
Partei Bürgermeister aus Städten aus der
aus der Ostukraine aus dem russisch
besetzten Gebieten im Moment in ihren
Rathäusern nicht arbeiten können und die
das von Lemberg austun und es hat uns
zutiefst beeindruckt mit welchem Mut mit
welcher Entschlossenheit mit welchem
Optimismus und welcher Zuversicht sie
trotz der widrigen Umstände die dort
herrschen in diesen Winter gehen wir
haben aber auch sehr gut zugehört was
uns zu sagen hatten und das Ergebnis
waren dann die 22 Millionen Euro in der
Bereinigungssitzung für 1.000 diese
Generatoren weil das angesichts der
Anschläge auf die Umspannwerke natürlich
die größte Sorge ist dass uns nicht nur
in Lemberg sondern in allen Kommunen und
die tausenden diese Generatoren werden
sicherlich auch nicht an den Lemberg
landen sondern solidarisch aufgeteilt
sondern solidarisch aufgeteilt werden
dort wo sie am aller nötigsten sind aber
daran hängt es ob es nicht nur Wärme
geben wird in diesem Winter ob es nicht
nur Strom geben wird sondern auch ob es
fließend Wasser geben wird und wir haben
auch mit vielen Flüchtlingen gesprochen
dort besonders beeindruckt das will ich
dann auch noch kurz erzählen hat uns der
Besuch von über 200 Frauen und Kindern
die im in der VIP-Lounge des dortigen
Fußballstadions das ich hoffe ich
spreche das richtig
ausnett das ist eher ein Fußballstadion
weil die ja vertrieben sind in Donalds
und dieser Fußballverein und seinem
Fanclub betreuen dort seit vielen vielen
Monaten alleine ohne Unterstützung von
außen über 200 Frauen und Kinder und
UNICEF betreut die Kinder im unteren
Teil des Fußballstadions wenn man sich
das angeguckt hat
wenn man sich das angeschaut hat auch
wie diese über 200 Frauen und Kinder
dort leben die alle aus den russisch
besetzten Gebieten geflohen sind die
schwerste Traumata erlebt und erlitten
haben und die uns trotzdem in unseren
Gesprächen im tiefsten Inbrunst der
Überzeugung gesagt haben sie wollen
nicht fliehen sie wollen da bleiben weil
sie sich natürlich auch mit den anderen
Frauen über die traumatischen Erlebnisse
die sie gehabt haben
austauschen können wenn man denn keine
psychologische Betreuung hat und die
haben wir wieder hier noch sonst wo so
viele Psychiater gibt es überhaupt nicht
für all die traumatisiert Menschen dann
ist das Reden untereinander mit Menschen
die das gleiche erlebt und der Lippen
haben wie man selber das Wichtigste und
die Kinder davon konnten wir uns
überzeugen die waren wirklich fröhlich
wie in einem wie in einem Kindergarten
in Deutschland die Kinder und
Jugendlichen wurden dort schulisch
betreut die
it-versorgung dort ist ja teilweise
besser und die Menschen professioneller
in diesem Sinne als bei uns und es hat
tiefsten Eindruck bei uns hinterlassen
was ein Fußballverein auf eigene
Initiative zu leisten imstande ist und
wie die Frauen und die Kinder auch
darauf reagieren mit welcher Dankbarkeit
ich will das hier wirklich kurz erwähnen
es gab keine Betten da liegt Matratze an
Matratze an Matratze an Matratze auf dem
Fußboden und dazwischen steht immer ein
Stuhl ein Stuhl für die Garderobe und
die Habseligkeiten desjenigen der in
diesen auf dieser Matratze nächtigt und
so sind die dort schon teilweise seit
Monaten untergebracht und obwohl wenn
man mit ihnen über die Telefonate mit
ihren Männern an der Front spricht
natürlich sie im Tränen ausbrechen so
ist von diesen in diesen Gesprächen doch
eine unglaubliche Stärke uns
entgegengeschlagen und eine Zuversicht
und der feste Wille dort zu bleiben auf
die Männer zu warten und sich eben auch
um die noch vorhandenen älteren
Angehörigen in den besetzen russischen
Gebieten zu kümmern und mit denen
täglich zu sprechen und vor dem
Hintergrund sind wir nach Hause gekommen
von dieser Reise haben eine unglaubliche
Hilfsbereitschaft in Moldau erlebt
Carsten Körber du hast über die
wirtschaftliche Situation in Moldau
berichtet und wenn ich höre wie vorhin
beim Einzelplan Fünfer hier für die AFD
über die Moldau gesprochen hat dann wäre
es vielleicht doch für Ihren Horizont
besser gewesen sie werden mitgekommen
sie waren ja Bericht erstatte auch für
diesen Bereich da hätten sie vielleicht
noch was lernen können aber sei darum
wir jedenfalls haben die Erfahrung
mitgenommen dass die Bereitschaft auch
der Leute den molder auch der Leute in
Südpolen unglaublich groß ist mit den
Flüchtlingen alles zu teilen und sie mit
offenen Herzen einzunehmen und das hat
uns schon auch demütig gemacht
Zusammenhalt in der Zeitenwende das ist
so ein bisschen die Überschrift über
dieser zweiten dritten Lesung unseres
Bundeshaushaltes den die zeitenwände die
wurde oft in den Mund genommen wenn es
um das Feld um das Militär zum Beispiel
ging aber die muss auf jeden Fall
dekliniert werden für jeden Haushalt und
so auch ganz bestimmt für diesen
Haushalt wie auch für denen das
Auswärtigen Amtes und weil der Bezug
schon hergestellt worden ist zu der
ersten Lesung naja ich habe es ja schon
versucht in der ersten Lesung zu
erläutern auch in ziemiak zum Beispiel
dass man nicht Äpfel mit Birnen
vergleichen darf dass man immer nur ein
fertigen Haushalt mit einem fertigen
Haushalt ein ist mit einem ist und nicht
ein Regierungsentwurf den muss man immer
mit einem Regierungsentwurf vergleichen
und wenn das so ist dann ist es
natürlich nicht überraschend weil wir
haben das angekündigt hier im September
dass dieser Haushalt jetzt um eine
Milliarde gewachsen ist und ich sage
Ihnen das ist nicht das Ende der Fahnen
denn es sind ja
es sind ja fünf Milliarden Euro im
Einzelplan 60 zur Krisenvorsorge gewesen
und wir haben davon je zwei Milliarden
in der Bereinigungssitzung aufgelöst zu
Recht eine Milliarde für humanitäre
Hilfe beim Auswärtigen Amt eine
Milliarde im Bereich der des
Ministeriums für Entwicklung zusammen
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung aber
es ist eine Vorsorge und wir sehen dass
unsere Regierung ja leider muss man
sagen im Moment auf sehr sehr vielen
internationalen Konferenzen Flagge
zeigen muss
wie die Rolle Deutschlands international
außerhalb des militärischen ist und wie
wir unsere Rolle dort auch gerecht
werden und das werden wir und die G7
Präsidentschaft in der
g7-präsidentschaft hat Olaf Scholz hat
darauf heute hingewiesen
haben wir sehr wohl Initiative
übernommen um auch unter unseren G7
Partnern dafür zu werben dass wir
gemeinsam mehr tun ich daran erinnern
dass unsere Ministerin Svenja Schulze
schon im Mai im Rahmen der
g7-präsidentschaft des Bündnis für
Sicherheit für Ernährungssicherheit
globaler Ebene ergriffen hat und all dem
Folgen Taten und vor dem Hintergrund wir
haben die Kopf nun gerade hinter uns
gebracht die hätte erfolgreicher sein
dürfen wenn es nach uns allen gegangen
werden aber es Step by Step es bedeutet
aber dass wir überall auch in den
nächsten 12 Monaten werden Flaggen
Flagge zeigen müssen und Flagge zeigen
wollen und voran zu gehen in der
Bewältigung der großen Krisen zum Wohle
der Menschen überall
und wir haben nicht nur eine Milliarde
Euro für den Haushalt 23 am 10 November
on top geschlossenen sind jetzt bei über
12 Milliarden Euro für den Gesamtetat
wir haben am gleichen Tag das wird
manchmal vergessen auch fast eine
Milliarde beschlossen die nämlich unser
Koalitionsausschuss Anfang September
vereinbart hatte um die
Ernährungssicherheit weltweit zu
gewährleisten das ist noch für 2022
beschlossen worden und wir haben 495
Millionen Euro am Tag der
Bereinigungssitzung beschlossen zu für
das für das BMZ davon gehen 275
Millionen in die sonderinitiative die
bisher hieß eine Welt ohne Hunger und
die jetzt heißt Transformation der Agrar
und ernährungssysteme 275 Millionen Plus
und 170 Millionen Plus für die
Krisenbewältigung
Wiederaufbau und die Infrastruktur und
50 Millionen für das World food-programm
das addiert sich dann noch mit Summen
die an anderer Stelle parallel
beschlossen wurden und auch wenn wir das
jetzt für 2022 geschlossen haben und sie
das in dem Haushalt 2023 nicht finden
werden so ist doch klar das kann ja erst
ausgegeben werden von der Regierung nach
dem Beschluss des Parlaments über den
Haushalt und das entfaltet natürlich
seine Wirkung seine gute Wirkung
weltweit dann 2023 und unterstützt
diesen Etat insofern im nächsten Jahr
übrigens das nur nach rechtlich 495
Millionen Euro gehen an das Auswärtige
Amt für humanitäre Hilfe im Ausland ich
möchte meinen sie schließen damit dass
ich an Willy Brandt erinnert der vor 45
Jahren in Genf gesagt hat die reichen
Nationen werden nicht reich bleiben wenn
die armen Häuser der Menschheit wachsen
ähm was für ein WE Widerspruch vor so
langer Zeit in diesem Sinne wünsche ich
uns allen gute Beratung stimmen Sie
bitte zu das können sie von Herzen gerne
tun und wohlauf
Bettina Hagedorn war das für die
SPD-Fraktion wie ist eine der
Berichterstatterin für diesen Einzelplan
das sind ja die Haushälter die wirklich
sich mit jedem einzelnen Titel noch mal
beschäftigen und sie haben es ja auch
gemerkt Bettina Hagedorn hat ja noch mal
einige davon vorgetragen auch
angesprochen hat Sie Michael espendeler
von der afd-fraktion der jetzt noch mal
Rederecht hat
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer im Saal
und bei Youtube der Etat des
Bundesministeriums für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung für 2023
Ausgaben in Höhe von 12,2 Milliarden
Euro umfassen aber der Name dieses
Ministeriums alleine ist schon ein
Etikettenschwindel Deutschland hat sich
vor Jahren von einer richtigen
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit
verabschiedet stattdessen ist
mittlerweile der Fokus des BMZ auf
Direktzahlungen und Zahlungen
internationale Organisation gerichtet
das ist so ziemlich das Gegenteil von
klug denn wir hätten in Deutschland ganz
andere Potenziale Deutschland hat ein
Wirtschaftsmodell das zu großen Teilen
auf dem Export von hochwertigen
Maschinen Fahrzeugen und Chemieprodukten
basiert das ist eigentlich eine sehr
gute Ausgangsbasis für die
Zusammenarbeit mit Ländern die selbst
wachsen und wirtschaftlich unabhängig
sein wollen es wäre doch sehr leicht bei
dem Aufbau einer nachhaltigen
Forstwirtschaft in Uganda vertraglich
fest zu ziehen dass deutsche
Fahrzeugbauer die Maschinen dafür
liefern so kann man den Regenwald retten
und gleichzeitig deutsche Interessen
vertreten der lei Gedanken findet man im
B ZMZ aber seit langem nicht mehr der
Abstieg der deutschen Wirtschaft im
internationalen Vergleich ist von der
Politik der Altparteien selbst
verschuldet und er wurde mit verursacht
von der falschen Schwerpunktsetzung
dieses Ministeriums
die Haushaltsberatung haben uns in
dieser Überzeugung noch weiter gestärkt
und deswegen kürzen wir den Etat des BMZ
auch in erheblichen Umfang und zwar bei
den Zuschüssen wir haben Streichungen in
Höhe von 5,9 Milliarden Euro beantragt
außerdem weitreichende Umschichtungen
denn das Geld wird im BMZ faktisch
verbrannt also muss man es ihnen
entziehen
[Applaus]
unser Ziel ist es Deutschland durch
seine seine wirtschaftlichen
Spitzenleistung zu einem wertvollen
Partner in einer multipolaren Welt zu
machen und mit anderen Ländern auf
Augenhöhe zusammen zu arbeiten zum
beiderseitigen Vorteil so können wir den
Wohlstand in Deutschland erhalten und
gleichzeitig andere Länder bei ihrem
Wirtschaftsaufbau unterstützen doch in
der Regierung hört man jetzt immer
wieder überall wo Deutschland rausgeht
geht China rein und dann diesen Satz
zeigt sich das Missverständnis der
deutschen Bundesregierung china macht es
nämlich ganz anders als diese
Bundesregierung China setzt auch
wirtschaftlich Zusammenarbeit auf
Kredite und verzichtet auf das Verteilen
von Almosen und bei aller Kritik die an
der Menschenrechtslage in China mehr als
angebracht ist diese Art der Interessen
geleiteten Politik wird von
internationalen Partnern geschätzt China
exportierte zum Beispiel im Jahr 2021
elektrische Maschinen Apparate und
Geräte mit einem Anteil am Gesamtexport
des Landes von
15,7%, das entspricht ungefähr
529 Milliarden US-Dollar
ein Wechsel der Strategie und der
Schwerpunktsetzung im BMZ ist also
dringend nötig Frau Ministerin
der zweite Aspekt in diesem
Haushaltsplan ist die Entwicklungshilfe
selber also Zahlung an Staaten oder
internationale Programme
Entwicklungshilfe kann nämlich
tatsächlich einen Beitrag leisten
starten zu stabilisieren und so Terror
oder Flüchtlingsbewegung zu unterbinden
es liegt also auch im deutschen
Interesse beispielsweise Zahlungen an
das Wild Ernährungsprogramm zu leisten
was auch meine Fraktion ausdrücklich
unterstützt das verhindert dass
Millionen Menschen an Unterernährung
sterben aus ihrer Heimat gerissen werden
und in andere Länder fliehen müssen
[Applaus]
ein guter Haushälter muss ich aber
naturgemäß Fragen Frau Hagedorn erfüllen
denn alle Ausgaben und Programme des BMZ
einen solchen sinnvollen Zweck und ist
es überhaupt angebracht im deutschen
Steuerzahler die notwendigen Euros dafür
zu rauben wie Sie unseren
kürzungsanträgen entnehmen können lautet
die Antwort nein das BMZ ist ein
riesiges Ministeriums mit ihm zu Risiken
Budget das Tausende Programme weltweit
unterhält oder sich an ihnen beteiligt
ich möchte hier einfach mal einige
Projekte nennen die der deutsche
Steuerzahler nun wirklich nicht
finanzieren muss das BMZ finanziert zum
Beispiel eine regionale Seniorenprogramm
in Asien für schlappe 600.000 €. das BMZ
fördert die Young Film School einen
Verein zu Förderung junger burnesischer
Film und Videokünstler das BMZ fördert
auch die Entwicklung der
Hauskrankenpflege in Georgien mit
268.000 Euro warum wieso weshalb keine
Ahnung völlig unklar ist auch wieso ist
Aufgabe des deutschen Steuerzahlers ist
die gute Arbeit entlang der
erschöpfungskette mit 761.000 Euro zu
fördern was auch immer die mit dem Geld
jetzt eigentlich machen das gehört
definitiv nicht zu den Aufgaben des
deutschen Steuerzahlers mit 900.000 Euro
die Gewerkschaften in leithain Amerika
zu bezahlen so zieht sich das durch den
gesamten Einzelplan und es kann einem
wirklich übel werden wenn man das so
liest was mit dem Geld der Steuerzahler
passiert und Frau Hagedorn wenn Ihnen
jetzt über Wert zu Entspannung kann ich
Ihnen nur den sensorischen Garten in
Georgien empfehlen die in der deutschen
Steuerzahler mit 12.000 € finanziert hat
das Flugticket müssen sie aber selber
bezahlen
zusammenfassend der Handlungsbedarf im
BNZ ist immens Besserung mit dieser
Bundesregierung aber nicht in Sicht und
da wir uns dem deutschen Volk und
Steuerzahler verpflichtet fühlen lehnen
wir diesen Etat ab und Frau Hagedorn
noch mal zu ihrer Eingebung gerade was
ich im Einzelplan 05 gefordert haben
waren bessere Kontrollen es ist ein Fakt
dass Deutschland Geld in korrupte Länder
überweist und ja wir wollen helfen aber
dann muss es auch kontrolliert werden
dann kommen
[Applaus]
die kontrollmechanisierung
jetzt hat das Wort die Kollegin der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen Susanne
Menge
[Applaus]
gehörte frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren allen voran
ein großes Dankeschön an unsere
Haushälter in den für das Meistern
dieser schwierigen
Haushaltsverhandlungen es ist gelungen
die noch im Regierungsentwurf geplanten
Kürzungen erheblich abzumildern und das
ist wichtig denn die Herausforderungen
angesichts der großen globalen Krisen
sind wirklich groß die Zielrichtung
heißt in der internationalen
Partnerschaftsarbeit trotz der
angespannten Haushaltslage den
weltweiten Krisen Konflikten und
Katastrophen auch begegnen zu können den
Etat des Bundesministeriums für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung haben wir um rund 1
Milliarde Euro aus der Krisenvorsorge
aufgestockt die Gelder sollen
insbesondere der sogenannten
Übergangshilfe dem Welt
Ernährungsprogramm den Vereinten
Nationen und der Gesellschaft für
internationale Zusammenarbeit zur
Verfügung stehen ein paar Beispiele dazu
50 Millionen Euro mehr für das
Welternährungsprogramm
163 Millionen Euro mehr für
Krisenbewältigung und Wiederaufbau
persönlich freue ich mich insbesondere
über die Zuweisung von zusätzlich 8
Millionen Euro für you and women diese
sollen den feministischen Ansatz der
Entwicklungspolitik stärken wir haben
zudem für das laufende Haushaltsjahr
eine Milliarde Euro für globale
Ernährungssouveränität aus dem
Entlastungspaket freigegeben damit
können wir schnell und direkt Hilfe
gegen die akute Hungerkrise leisten klar
ist aber auch dass dies erst der Anfang
sein kann mit diesem Haushalt ist es
nicht getan wir müssen dieses Engagement
und wir wollen dieses Engagement auch in
den kommenden Jahren weiterführen
internationale Partnerschaftsarbeit wird
in Zukunft geprägt sein davon
ernährungs-
und Biodiversität voranzubringen so wie
zivilgesellschaftlicher Arbeit und
multilaterale Organisationen zu
unterstützen dementsprechend benötigen
Sie eine solide finanzierungsperspektive
und Grundlage wir müssen verehrte Damen
und Herren uns daher dringend Gedanken
darüber machen wie wir hinkommen zu
einer wirkungsvolleren Projektarbeit
diese müsste anders als jetzt
langfristig terminiert und auch
finanziert werden
wenn man Zuhörer setzt dieser Haushalt
wichtige Signale in einer Welt in der
jungen Menschen offenbar eine
optimistische Zukunftsperspektive
aufgrund globaler Krisen und
Katastrophen abhanden kommt eine dieser
globalen Krisen betrifft die Bildung
weltweit die durch Corona massiv
verschlimmert wurde zwei Dritteln der
zehnjährigen Kinder auf dieser Welt ist
Grundbildung verwehrt sie sind nicht in
der Lage eine einfache Geschichte lesen
und verstehen zu können sie haben nicht
die Möglichkeit ihr eigenes Potenzial zu
entdecken es auszuschöpfen und folglich
auch kaum eine gute Chance eine
existenzsichernde Arbeit zu finden wie
sollen diese Kinder an die so immens
große Anforderungen in Zukunft gestellt
werden diese selbstbestimmt gestalten um
den unberechenbaren Anforderungen der
kommenden Jahrzehnte beizukommen
appelliere ich an uns alle wir müssen
mehr in Bildung und insbesondere die
frühkindliche und die Grundbildung
investieren
Jugend ist unsere Zukunft das sagt sich
so leicht daher den denn wir die
Generation der Eltern und Großeltern
belasten mit dem Irrglauben an stetiges
Wachstum diese Zukunft auf dramatische
Weise damit wir einander verstehen
Probleme analysieren friedliche
staatensysteme erhalten und auch Frieden
schaffen können brauchen wir vor allem
Wachstum für die Ressource gute Bildung
überall auf der Welt ich danke ihnen
fürs zuhören
Susanne Menge war das für die Fraktion
Bündnis wenn 90 die Grünen und ihr folgt
jetzt hier als nächster Rednerin für die
Linksfraktion Cornelia Möhring
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Frau Ministerin
Schulze ich habe gelesen dass die
Haushälter der Ampel den Haushalt also
den Einzelplan 23 als Signal für eine
friedliche Entwicklung in der Welt
bezeichnen meine Fraktion kann das nicht
unterschreiben angesichts der
gegenwärtigen Weltlage würde ich sogar
den Haushalt tendenziell kurzsichtig
nennen wir sind auf dem Weg in die
klimahalle sagt
un-generalsekretärisch und leider müssen
wir heute ergänzen einige Länder sind
aufgrund des Klimawandels auf dem highw
in den Hungertod die Zuspitzung der
Ernährungskrise zeichnet sich seit
Jahren ab in Ostafrika steht die fünfte
Dürreperiode in Folge bevor seit über
zwei Jahren beobachten wir die
steigenden Preise für Nahrungsmittel
Düngemittel sind kaum noch erschwinglich
und damit steigen natürlich auch für die
Hilfsorganisationen die Ausgaben weniger
Menschen können versorgt werden Projekte
müssen ihre Leistung einschränken das
alles berücksichtigen sie im Haushalt
unzureichen
äußerst dramatisch ist die Situation in
Somalia von den 16 Millionen Einwohnern
hat fast die Hälfte nicht genug zu essen
1,5 Millionen Kinder unter fünf Jahren
sind Fehler nähert mindestens 230.000
Menschen sind akut vom Hungertod bedroht
viele von ihnen werden den Jahreswechsel
nicht erleben wir stehen vor einer
verheerenden Katastrophe mahnen die
Vereinten Nationen und sagen nur ein
massiver Mitteleinsatz können die Anzahl
der Toten wenigstens verringern klar ist
natürlich
Nothilfe alleine reicht nicht um die
Ernährungskrise in den vielen
betroffenen Regionen und Ländern zu
lösen es muss mehr für ein
strukturellenität getan werden und
deshalb bin ich Frau Ministerin Schulze
immer noch sehr skeptisch was von ihnen
viel gepriesene Bündnis für globale
Ernährungssicherheit angeht ja es ist
mehr als nötig dass Sie
Nahrungsmittelkrise durch kurzfristige
Nothilfemaßnahmen abgemildert wird aber
welchen konkreten Beitrag ihr neues
Bündnis dazu leisten will ist auch acht
Monate nach seiner Gründung völlig
unklar bisher wirkt es eher wie eine
Gewissens Beruhigung zu einer
umfassenden strukturellen Problemlösung
wird es wohl kaum beitragen
aber stattdessen dass sie jetzt für die
Beteiligung und Beiträge zu diesem
Bündnis bei vielen Institutionen
Stiftung Philanthropen Privatunternehmen
bitte bitte machen ziehen sie doch
besser die krisenprofiteure zur
Verantwortung bitten die zur verfassen
denn während steigende Energie und
Grundnahrungsmittel für Preise für
Energie und gründungsmittel für Dünger
und weitere Agrar Güter millionenfaches
Leid verursachen klingelt bei einigen
Konzernen ordentlich die Kasse und jetzt
meine Damen und Herren bei der
Klimakonferenz der Kopf 27 wurde nun der
nächste unkonkrete vor uns Leben gerufen
seit vielen Jahren fordern die Länder
des globalen Südens einen Finanztopf für
Verluste und Schäden der am stärksten
von der Klimakrise betroffenen Staaten
ein faktisch leeres Konto hatten die
Länder sich aber bestimmt nicht
vorgestellt denn wer einzahlt und vor
allem welche Summen steht in den Sternen
und ist mindestens bis zur knapp 28 in
Dubai verschoben das Hauptproblem bleibt
doch sowieso der Klimawandel wird
dadurch nicht gestoppt und die
Lebensbedingungen der Menschen werden
mit dem Einsatz fossiler Energien immer
weiter zerstört und ihre Einkaufstour
für fossile Energien in den letzten
Monaten trägt dazu bei dass das als
absolute Grenze definierte zwei Grad
Ziel immer mehr außer Reichweite gerät
sie richten also einen Fond für Verluste
und Schäden ein und produzieren
gleichzeitig Verluste und Schäden munter
weiter die 170 Millionen die Deutschland
für diesen forschendiert kommt dann
ausgerechnet aus dem ohnehin schon
geschrumpfenetal des BMZ es sind 190
Millionen weniger für diesen Etat in
diesem Jahr und ich finde das ist
wirklich kein Pappenstiel die
Klimamittel müssen zusätzlich zur
Verfügung gestellt werden und dürfen
nicht zurücklassen der klassischen EZ
gehen
sie feiern hier Frau Ministerin Schulz
ist unterstelle ich Ihnen jetzt mal in
ihrer Rede gleich aber auch Bettina
Hagedorn hat es schon getan feiern Sie
sich für die zusätzliche Milliarde die
sie aus der allgemeinen Krisenvorsorge
also dem Einzelplan 60 bekommen aber
eigentlich verringern sie damit nur die
beachtlichen Kürzungen der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit gefordert und
vor allem auch für erforderlich gehalten
haben sie Frau Ministerin Schulze einmal
3,3 Milliarden und nicht nur eine
Milliarde ich finde sehr bedauerlich
dass sie nicht mehr Kampfesgeist gezeigt
haben und da mehrmittel durchzusetzen
und machen wir uns doch nichts vor um
den Auswirkungen der multiplen Krisen
wirklich etwas entgegenzusetzen oder wie
sie sagen ein Signal für eine friedliche
in der Entwicklung in der Welt zu
sichern braucht es deutlich mehr globale
Solidarität statt weiterer nationaler
Egoismen und es braucht endlich globale
Umverteilung damit die Krisen Profiteure
auch für die Krisen bezahlen die sie
hervorgerufen haben vielen Dank
Herr Cornelia Möhring von der Linken hat
auch die Bundesministerin angesprochen
das Finja Schulz sehen sie haben sie auf
der Regierungsbank gesehen zwischendrin
die wird natürlich ja auch noch das Wort
ergreifen ihn ungefähr ja 12 bis 13
Minuten jetzt hören wir aber erstmal
Claudia Raffelhüschen für die Liberalen
spricht sie
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen schon vor der
Bereinigungssitzung für den Haushalt
2023 gab es noch mal eine beachtliche
Aufstockung für die
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit aus dem
Haushalt 2022 im Rahmen des
entlastungspakets 3 wird eine ganze
Milliarde für globale
Ernährungssicherheit eingesetzt und
davon 495 Millionen Euro durch das BMZ
das Geld fließt in das
weltanährungsprogramm und in die
Umsetzung des Bündnisses für globale
Ernährungssicherheit das unter der
deutschen G7 Präsidentschaft mit der
Weltbank ins Leben gerufen wurde
das ist eine großeartige Nachricht und
sie widerlegt all diejenigen Stimmen die
in den letzten Wochen und Monaten
behauptet hatten dass Deutschland zu
wenig mache und seine internationalen
Verpflichtung nicht gerecht werden
das ist schlicht und ergreifend falsch
und wir sollten uns unser großes
Engagement gerade auch im Vergleich mit
den anderen westlichen Ländern nicht
kleinreden lassen eine ganz
hervorragende Nachricht war auch die
Präsentation des Global food and
nutrition Security Dashboards mit diesem
schlüsselinstrument kann das Bündnis für
globale Ernährungssicherheit künftig
noch schneller koordinierter und
effektiver auf Ernährungskrisen
reagieren das Dashboard liefert uns
quasi in Echtzeit Daten über die
Ernährungssicherheit in einzelnen
Regionen und zeigt auf was bereits getan
wird und was noch zu tun ist das ist
technisch das ist technisch und auch
politisch an ganz wichtiger Schritt denn
zu tun gibt es weiterhin eine ganze
Menge und daher hat auch der
Haushaltsausschuss für 2023 beschlossen
dem BMZ weitere Mitte in Höhe von 962,
sechs Millionen Euro aus der globalen
Krisenvorsorge zur Verfügung zu stellen
insgesamt liegt der Etat damit rund 1,1
Milliarden Euro über dem
Regierungsentwurf bei knapp 12,2
Millionen Euro Milliarden Euro sorry
zusammen mit der erwähnten halben
Milliarde aus dem Entlastungspaket 3
nähern wir uns also einen
entwicklungsetat von 13 Milliarden fast
kein anderes Land leistet mehr weder in
Totalen Zahlen noch in Relation zum
Bruttoinlandsprodukt oder bruttonational
Einkommen
dass dieser Haushaltszahlen noch einmal
ein ganz anderes Gewicht bekommen wenn
sie in die Realität umgesetzt werden
konnte ich im Oktober auf der Reise nach
Polen Moldau und die Ukraine erleben die
ich als hauptberichterstatterin leiten
durfte wir alle die mit dabei waren sind
immer noch schwer beeindruckt von denen
zum Teil grausam Schicksal aber auch von
dem unglaublichen Kampfgeist und
Optimismus mit dem die Menschen vor Ort
diese Herausforderungen annehmen
egal mit wem wir gesprochen haben es gab
kein jammern oder klagen sondern es gab
nur hochmotivierte verantwortliche die
perfekt organisiert waren und sehr gut
begründete Wünsche für konkrete
Unterstützung an uns gerichtet haben es
ist daher ein ganz wunderbares Signal
dass wir im Rahmen der Bereinigung jetzt
eine noch einmal helfen konnten die
Stadt Liv oder Lemberg
bekommt 10 Millionen Euro für
Notstromaggregate und 12 Millionen für
den Ausbau eines Krankenhauses mit
prothesenwerkstatt die Pläne liegen
schon beim Bürgermeister in der
Schublade es kann quasi sofort losgehen
es war für mich ein neues und auch sehr
befriedigendes Gefühl als Haushälterin
mit eigenen Augen zu sehen was gebraucht
wird und es dann so unmittelbar umsetzen
zu können an dieser Stelle daher noch
mal mein herzliches Dankeschön an alle
Beteiligten besonders an Bettina
Hagedorn und alle Mitstreiter im BMZ und
bei der GEZ
die das gemeinsam ermöglichen
weniger erfreulich aber deshalb
mindestens genauso wichtig war es auch
einmal vor Ort vergleichen zu können
welche Hilfen wirklich gut sind und
welche nur gut gemeint
nachdem im Sommer der äußerst
ernüchternde Bericht des französischen
Instituts für internationale Beziehungen
für über die Arbeit einiger NGOs
veröffentlicht wurde hatte ich an uns
alle appelliert hier genauer
hinzuschauen das haben wir nun getan und
müssen im Institut in Teilen leider
recht geben Yoga und
makrame-kurse mögen in vielen
Situationen und Ländern eine gute Sache
sein ein Hilfsangebot für traumatisierte
Ukrainerin als Hilfsangebot haben sie
ihnen in der Form keinen Dienst
geleistet und uns als Haushälter ehrlich
gesagt fassungslos gemacht es bleibt
also unabdingbar dass wir und damit
meine ich uns Parlamentarier genauso wie
die Regierung immer wieder überprüfen
und hinterfragen wo unsere Gelder landen
was sich bewährt hat und wo NGOs auch
etablierte gute NGOs ihre Angebote
präzisieren und auch praxistauglicher
machen müssen sehr begrüßenswert ist in
diesem Zusammenhang auch der
maßgabebeschluss an das Auswärtige Amt
und das BMZ den Aufbau einer
einheitlichen länderdatenbank weiter zu
forcieren
diese Datenbank soll uns Abgeordneten
aber auch anderen Akteuren in Zukunft
alle relevanten Informationen über die
Aktivitäten des Bundes im Ausland quasi
auf Knopfdruck bereitstellen also in
welchem Land und in welcher Region mit
welchen Partnern zu welchen Themen mit
wie viel Geld welche Projekte
durchgeführt oder gefördert werden
ähnlich wie das Dashboard zur
Ernährungssicherheit was ich eben
erwähnt hatte wird dies ein wirklich
weiter wichtiger Schritt sein um das
deutsche Engagement der
entwicklungszusammenarbeiten noch besser
zu koordinieren transparenter und
effektiver zu machen insofern bin ich
zuversichtlich dass nach den
erfolgreichen Haushaltsverhandlungen nun
auch weiterhin erfolgreiches
Regierungshandeln folgen wird und wir
mit den Geldern die vom Parlament
bereitgestellt wurden eine Menge
hilfeleisten können der Dank aus Liv und
anderen Städten und Regionen ist dafür
denke ich die schönste Motivation
Hermann Gröhe hat das Wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen Frau Ministerin in der letzten
Nacht haben russische Raketen ein
Krankenhaus in saporita getroffen dabei
die Entbindungsstation zerstört ein
Säugling starb dabei
angesichts der russischen Angriffe auf
das Stromnetz warnt der Direktor der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation Europa Hans
kluge Zitat der Winter wird für
Millionen von Menschen in der Ukraine
lebensbedrohlich sein
Zitat Ende aus dem Völkerrechts wäre in
Angriffskrieg ist längst ein
verbrecherischer Vernichtungskrieg gegen
die Menschen in der Ukraine geworden
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir mit
ganzer Kraft an der Seite der Menschen
in der Ukraine stehen und ich danke
ausdrücklich den Berichterstatterin und
Berichterstatter für Ihren Besuch und
auch für schwere bewegenden Schilderung
von dieser Reise bisher sind rund 600
Millionen aus dem Etat des
Bundesministeriums für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit für die Unterstützung der
Menschen in der Ukraine zur Verfügung
gestellt worden und manchen in unserem
Land mag es ja zunächst überraschen dass
die Ukraine ja nach ihrem pro
kopfeinkommen eine Entwicklungsland ist
und die schreckliche Wahrheit ist dass
die soziale und ökonomische Entwicklung
dieses Landes ja weiter dramatisch
zurückgeworfen wird insofern wird hier
noch sehr viel mehr zu tun sein aber es
hilft jetzt wenn Wohnraum für
Binnenvertriebene und Flüchtlinge
geschaffen wird die medizinische
Versorgung aufrechterhalten wird
psychosoziale Beratung für Menschen die
uns sehr vieles erfahren und erleben
mussten Bildungsangebote aufrecht
erhalten werden und ich möchte sehr
bewusst den Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern des BMZ aber auch die
Partnerin und Partner in der
Zivilgesellschaft der Gesellschaft für
internationale Zusammenarbeit der KfW
und allen anderen für diesen Kraftakt
danken
ich glaube es ist gut und zeigt sich
ähnlich wie am Beginn der
corona-pandemie das unsere
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit so flexibel
ist dann ein solches Handeln zu
ermöglichen und da ich die GEZ erwähnt
habe möchte ich auch der jetzt
ausgeschiedenen vorstandssprecherin
Tanja Gönner für jahrelange
herausragende Arbeit herzlich danken und
zugleich
den neuen vorstandsbrecher Thorsten
Schäfer-Gümbel alles Gute für diese
wichtige Arbeit wünschen
angesichts dieses Kraftakts den ich
begrüße verwundert es aber schon dass
sie glauben mit einem Etat der gemessen
an dem Jahr 2021 von 13,4 Milliarden um
über eine Milliarde geringer ausfällt in
einer so krisenhaften Zeit ausgeben zu
können ja es ist inzwischen eine
Milliarde draufgelegt worden aber es ist
für selbst Zufriedenheit die
gelegentlich hier anklingt wahrlich kein
Platz und sie sollten nicht vergessen
und es nicht nur der Opposition Anlassen
dass ihre Regierungsentwurf bei den
Partnern bei Brot für die Welt bei
Misereor bei der Welt Hungerhilfe und
bei vielen anderen mehr einen empörten
schreit es Entsetzens ausgelöst hat
übrigens angebracht diesen
Organisationen heute zu danken dass ihr
pro dazu beigetragen hat dass peinliche
Kürzungen etwa bei jungen woman und
anderen inzwischen zurückgenommen werden
konnten was noch kein aufwuchs und noch
keine besonders eindrucksvolle
feministische Politik ist aber immerhin
die Rücknahme schlimmer Kürze und viele
von uns kennen die eindrucksvollen
jungen Menschen die als
jugendbotschafter von One uns besuchen
und dafür werben diese Arbeit
vorzusetzen ihr Sprecher hat vor wenigen
Tagen zu der einen Milliarden gesagt wir
dürfen uns davon nicht blenden lassen es
reicht hinten und vorne nicht das sagen
diese jungen Leute ja 2021 gab es
Sondermittel im Bereich der
pandemiebekämpfung das will ich
ausdrücklich ansprechen aber wir
bräuchten sie jetzt als versteht Jungs
zur Pandemie Vorsorge
die Voraussetzung dafür zu schaffen dass
wir besser werden und das ist eine
schlechte Nachricht wenn beispielsweise
die Allianz für
diagnostikentwicklung Feind oder für
neue Medikamente unität auf Null
gestellt wird wer weiß wie wichtig
gerade die zur Verfügung Stellung
moderner Testverfahren in den ärmsten
Länder der Welt ist um rechtzeitig
Krankheiten und ihre Ausbreitung zu
festzustellen der muss nur sagen eine
solcher Einbruch in diesen wichtigen
Bereichen globaler Gesundheit ist falsch
meine Damen meine Herren wir haben
natürlich mit Interesse auch Ankündigung
wahrgenommen auch des Bundeskanzlers den
Anstieg der Klimafinanzierung die
Absicherung von klimakrisen die Mittel
zum Artenschutz der globale Fond bei
dessen Kürzung wir hier mehrfach
angesprochen haben gut dass da
nachgelegt wird die Polio Bekämpfung da
fragt sich nur bei diesen
begrüßenswerten Ankündigung des
Bundeskanzlers kennt er die traurige
Hinterlassenschaft des Finanzministers
Olaf Scholz im Finanzplan wonach dass
der BMZ Etat auf 10,7 20 24 auf 10,4
2026 singt korrigieren dass sie das
sonst werden ihre Versprechungen alles
ungedeckte Schecks meine Damen meine
Herren und als solche
tragen sie nicht zur deutschen
Verantwortung in der Welt war nein es
ist kein Anlass der Ampel zur
Selbstzufriedenheit vielmehr zu harten
Arbeit damit die
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit wieder den
Stellenwert erhält den sie dringend
braucht herzlichen Dank
sagt Hermann Gröhe hier der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der cdu/csu-fraktion und die Ministerin
hat jetzt das Wort hier ist Svenja
Schulze
zu ihrem Einzelplan
jetzt hier am Rednerpult
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mit dem vorgelegten
Haushaltsplan setzt die Bundesregierung
klare Prioritäten sie nimmt diejenigen
in den Blick die die Auswirkungen der
aktuellen multiplen Krisen am
schmerzhaftesten spüren sie setzt die
verfügbaren Mittel gezielt dafür ein die
Krisenfolgen abzufedern und
Gesellschaften widerstandsfähiger gegen
Krisen zu machen so auch jetzt mit dem
Einzelplan 23 für die internationale
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit mit den
zusätzlichen Geldern insbesondere aus
der allgemeinen Krisenvorsorge des
Einzelplans 60 stehen und insgesamt rund
12,2 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung das
ist für die deutsche Entwicklungspolitik
eine gute finanzielle Basis für das
kommende Jahr und es braucht eine
stabile
Entwicklungspolitik das ist aus zwei
Gründen ganz besonders wichtig zum einen
senden wir hier als Bundestag als
Bundesregierung eine ganz klare
Botschaft auch in Krisenzeiten bleibt
Deutschland solidarisch und ein
verlässlicher Partner für die Länder des
globalen Südens und auch in Krisenzeiten
verlieren wir die Ziele der Agenda 2030
für nachhaltige Entwicklung nicht aus
dem Blick das ist ein
unmissverständliches Signal und es ist
gerade jetzt besonders wichtig denn
Verlässlichkeit das ist es was vertrauen
erhält was Vertrauen schafft und
Vertrauen das ist die Grundvoraussetzung
für eine wirksame
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit nur so können
wir gemeinsam mit unseren Partnerländern
strukturelle Veränderungen anstoßen und
wichtige Reformen umsetzen für mehr
soziale Gerechtigkeit für mehr
Klimaschutz in der Welt
das bringt mich zum zweiten Grund warum
eine solide Entwicklungspolitik wichtig
ist sie stärkt unzählige Menschen
weltweit damit sie besser durch die
Krisenzeit kommen und sie trägt eben
dazu bei weltweit bessere
Zukunftsperspektiven zu schaffen ich
hatte heute das Vergnügen mit unseren
wz-referentinnen und Referenten in einer
Videokonferenz zu diskutieren das sind
wichtige Brückenköpfe in unsere
Partnerländer und sie haben noch mal
bestätigt wie wichtig Vertrauen wie
wichtig diese intensive Zusammenarbeit
ist aber wie genau machen wir das jetzt
wie schaffen wir dieses Vertrauen und
die Zukunftsperspektiven in der Ukraine
und das haben sie betont ich will das
aber noch mal hier herausheben in der
Ukraine werden die Mittel dafür sorgen
dass die Menschen wasserwärme Strom
medizinische Versorgung gehalten sie
können Sie so können Sie den Winter und
im russischen Angriffskrieg besser
trotzdem und ihre Heimat anfangen wieder
aufzubauen und das was wir dort machen
geht über humanitäre Nothilfe hinaus das
wirkt langfristig das wirkt jetzt schon
strukturbildend und sie haben es betont
Frau raffelhöschen sie sind ja unter
ihrer Leitung sind die
berichterstatterinnen und
Berichterstatter für den Einzelplan in
die Ukraine gereist die haben sich
selber ein Bild machen können von der
Lage vor Ort und ich will noch mal
ausdrücklich dafür danken dass die
fraktionsübergreifend dafür gesorgt
haben dass Deutschland die Menschen in
der Ukraine verlässlich wirksam
unterstützen kann
mit den Mitteln aus dem Einzelplan 23
werden wir jetzt auch das Bündnis für
globale Ernährungssicherheit weiter
voranbringen es muss jetzt darum gehen
zu verhindern dass die Folgen des
russischen Angriffs Kriegs die weltweite
Hungerkrise noch weiter eskalieren das
Bündnis sichert Existenzen es rettet
Leben etwa am Horn von Afrika im Nahen
Osten wo eben die Menschen ganz
besonders unter den steigenden Preisen
für Nahrungsmittel aber eben auch für
Dünger leiden und das Bündnis trägt
jetzt ganz konkret dazu bei die globale
Ernährungssicherheit auch langfristig zu
verbessern eine nachhaltige eine Klima
angepasste Landwirtschaft steigert die
Erträge macht die Ernten robuster so
wird eben die lokale Versorgung gestärkt
und die Armut reduziert und wir bekommen
weltweit sehr viel Applaus dafür dass
wir dieses Bündnis vorangetrieben haben
wir werden mit den Mitteln aber auch das
weitere aufspannen des globalen
Schutzschirms gegen klimarisiken
vorantreiben für den wir ja auf der Kopf
auf der Klimakonferenz den Trail Blazer
von lost and band damage bekommen haben
also eine Auszeichnung für dieses
wichtige Instrument der Schutzschirm
wird die Armen wird die vulnerabenden
Länder wie Banger der Veganer wie
Senegal das wird diesen Ländern helfen
die ganz besonders unter den Folgen des
Klimawandels leisten für jedes dieser
Länder wird ein umfassendes
absicherungspaket entwickelt und so sind
diese Länder dann besser auf
klimabedingte Katastrophen vorbereitet
sie können im Notfall den Menschen
schneller helfen und das hilft auch
klimabedingte Verluste und Schäden zu
begrenzen
ich würde auch in den kommenden Jahren
die Umsetzung unserer feministischen
Entwicklungspolitik weiter beschleunigen
ich weiß ihnen ist es nicht recht wenn
Frauen die gleichen Chancen die gleichen
Rechte und Respekt bekommen
schauen Sie in Ihrer Reihen ja muss man
dazu nicht sagen
aber mein Ziel ist es das 2023 3/4 der
Vorhaben zur Geschlechtergerechtigkeit
beitragen so eröffnen wir Frauen und
Mädchen neue Perspektiven wir
verschaffen Ihnen Gehör wir machen sie
zu aktiven mitgestalterinnen einer
nachhaltigen Entwicklung und die
wissenschaftliche Evidenz ist eindeutig
nur mit Frauen werden gesellschaftlich
sich nachhaltig entwickeln können
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das sind
jetzt nur einige wenige Beispiele dafür
wie wir die deutsche
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit im nächsten
Jahr auch wieder nutzen werden um die
Ziele der Agenda 2030 umzusetzen
Vertrauen
Zukunftsperspektive lassen sich aber nur
schaffen wenn es eben auch Planbarkeit
wenn es Verlässlichkeit gibt gerade der
weitere Verlauf des russischen
angriffskriegs gegen die Ukraine und
seine Folgen für die Entwicklungsländer
sind aber unsicher und daher ist es gut
dass im Einzelplan 60 für 20123 weiter
vorgesorgt ist und das im Notfall
weitere Mittel zur Verfügung stehen wir
müssen unsere Entwicklungspolitik auch
mittelfristig im Haushalt absichern und
stabil machen das ist wichtig für die
vielen Menschen und für die
zivilgesellschaftlichen Organisationen
die sich weltweit unter großem Einsatz
engagieren eine solide
Entwicklungspolitik stärkt Ihnen auf den
Rücken meine Damen und Herren mit diesem
Haushalt stellt sich die Bundesregierung
ihrer globalen Verantwortung und sie
setzt ein Zeichen der Hoffnung und des
Aufbruchs in Krisenzeiten ich danke noch
mal sehr dass der Haushalt so verbessert
wurde und dass sie liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das alles ermöglicht haben
vielen Dank
die entwicklungsministerin Svenja
Schulze
reinigungssitzungen wurde noch mal
nachgelegt der Haushaltsentwurf der
Bundesregierung sei nämlich ursprünglich
vor
11,08 Milliarden Euro für das kommende
Jahr für den entwicklungsetat das wären
immerhin 1,27 Milliarden Euro weniger
gewesen als in diesem Jahr und es gab ja
noch mal was oben drauf das ist ja jetzt
schon mehrfach angesprochen worden
und eine Tochter und ich möchte nicht
dass aufgrund des Geschlechts
irgendwelche Unterschiede gemacht werden
für mich sind das beides wunderbare
Kinder für mich sind es beides Menschen
und darum halten wir nichts von diesem
gender Quatsch
wir sprechen heute über den Haushalt des
Entwicklungsministeriums und für mich
ist es immer wieder ein erstaunliches
Schauspiel weil jedes Jahr sich die
Vertreter der alten Parteien mit
Forderungen nach mehr Geld überbieten
gegenseitig mehr Geld für linke NGOs
mehr Geld für korrupte Regime mehr Geld
für ihre fantasieprojekte und in diesem
Haus da wird offenbar Politik nicht an
der Wirkung gemessen sondern für sie ist
es immer ein Erfolg wenn sie möglichst
viel Geld für ihr Ministerium Hamstern
wenn also dieser Haushalt verabschiedet
wird dann werden wieder 25 Milliarden
oda-leistungen als Entwicklungshilfe
durch die Welt verteilt schreien sie
nicht so rein und machen heiße Luft
sonst wird es nichts mit dem 1,5 Grad
Ziel liebe Kollegin
und ich finde die Bürger haben einen
recht
darauf und wie die Bundesregierung mit
Steuergeld umgeht neulich durften wir
die Dominikanische Republik besuchen und
dort Entwicklungsprojekte anschauen
unter anderem fördert der deutsche
Steuerzahler dort recyclingprojekte in
Karibikraum und konkret sieht das so aus
seit eineinhalb Jahren stehen in Santo
Domingo zwei Container am Straßenrand
für den Besuch der deutschen
Abgeordneten natürlich frisch lackiert
in den Containern waren dann Infotafeln
und eine Maschine zum Zerkleinern von
Plastikmüll auf die Frage wie viel Müll
denn jetzt in den eineinhalb Jahren
recycelt worden sind da sagte mir der
Projektleiter Null
man habe es mal den lokalen
Bürgermeister für das Projekt gewinnen
müssen im Anschluss hat man uns dann
einen völlig vermüllten Strand gezeigt
aufräumen wollte den Strand niemand denn
die lokale Bevölkerung soll für die
Müllproblematik sensibilisiert werden
kostenpunkt für dieses Projekt vier
Millionen Euro für den deutschen
Steuerzahler und wissen sie das ist kein
Einzelfall hier sitzen Kollegen die
haben neulich in Kenia eine Fischfarm
besucht das schwimmt kein Fisch dafür
fließt aber das Geld Kollege Friedhof
und Kräuter könnten über diese
Absurditäten berichten weitere
Absurdität die Bundesregierung hat über
Jahre Entwicklungshilfe an Afghanistan
geleistet den Taliban wurden so
Entwicklungsprojekte im Wert von über 3
Milliarden Euro überlassen und jetzt
müssen deutsche Entwicklungshelfer und
afghanische ortskräfte auf Steuerzahler
Kosten auch noch aus Afghanistan
ausgeflogen nach Deutschland eingeflogen
werden und das verrückte daran ist
einfach folgendes die Bundesregierung
bezeichnet als ortskraft ungefähr jeden
der mal salopp gesagt eine Getränkekiste
für das BMZ geschleppt hast und
mittlerweile sind
22.000 dieser ortskräfte ausgeflogen
wurden ausgeflogen wurden von
Afghanistan nach Deutschland und was sie
machen ist jetzt gleichzeitig auch noch
neue ortskräfte in Afghanistan
anzuwerben sie fliegen die bestehenden
nach Deutschland aus und suchen
gleichzeitig neue man nennt sowas
staatlich geförderte Massenmigration
liebe Kollegen und dazu sagen wir als
AFD nein
während sie also Milliarden von Euro für
spaßprojekte durch die Welt verteilen
produzieren sie auch noch in Deutschland
Werbefilmchen Werbefilmchen in denen Sie
unsere Bürger auf einen drohenden
Blackout vorbereiten oder sie sprechen
über wärmehallen wissen sie
Entwicklungspolitik muss den Bürgern in
Deutschland nutzen und sie nicht in
Armut und Not führen das heißt für uns
konkret als AFD
straßenschienen und Fabriken mit
deutschen Unternehmen machen Sie doch
endlich mal lieferbindungen machen sie
mal feste lieferbindungen so dass
deutsche Unternehmen auch entsprechend
zu beteiligen sind macht die GEZ und
andere bis heute nicht ja und vielleicht
sogar am wichtigsten Rohstoffe die kann
es sein dass ein Ministerium für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung sich genau um sowas auch
kümmern sollte aber sowas überhaupt gar
nicht tut unsere Lieferketten in
Deutschland die reißen beim geringsten
Widerstand damit muss Schluss gemacht
werden kümmern sich endlich um ihren Job
sorgen sorgen dafür dass wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung auch
etwas für die Bürger hier in Deutschland
tut
[Applaus]
der Kollege Dr janniklas gesenhus hat
jetzt das Wort für Bündnis 90 Sekunden
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr frohnmeyer sie haben fünf
Minuten Redezeit darauf verwendet sich
einfach nur lustig zu machen und die
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit verächtlich
zu machen verächtlich zu machen das ist
niveaulos noch tiefer kann ihr Niveau
überhaupt nicht sinken als diese Rede
das waren Tiefpunkt der Debatte und das
ist diesen Hohen Haus auch nicht würdig
und ich will ihn eines mal ganz deutlich
sagen die Entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist
nicht der erfüllungshilfe ihrer
neokolonialen Träume schmecken sie sich
das entweder ab
und und im Gegensatz zu ihnen bin ich
auch regelmäßig zu Gast beim deutschen
evaluierungsinstitut der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit da habe ich
sie nicht gesehen im Beirat wenn sie da
den Diskussionen folgen würden dann
wüssten sie überwiegend ist die
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit wirksam hier
und da identifizieren wir die Stellen wo
wir noch nachbessern müssen unterm
Strich unterm Strich ist die Entwicklung
Zusammenarbeit wirksam und übrigens das
haben sie vorhin völlig falsch
suggeriert ist auch die Unterstützung
für die Entwicklung Zusammenarbeit in
der deutschen Bevölkerung hoch und das
aus guten Gründen
so jetzt zum eigentlichen Thema
meine Damen und Herren die
Weltklimakonferenz ja sie können ruhig
reinschreien jetzt müssen sie sich das
auch anhören die Weltklimakonferenz hat
gerade noch mal deutlich gemacht die
ökologische Krise ist eine der
Hauptbedrohung für globale Gerechtigkeit
weltweit und der globale Süden auch das
ist noch mal deutlich geworden in
Ägypten ist besonders verwundbar durch
die Klimakrise das können Sie auch mit
ihrer Klimawandel Leugner leider nicht
ändern deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir
auch Klimaschutz Naturschutz und
Umweltschutz ins Zentrum der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit stellen denn
Sicherheit Hunger Bekämpfung das braucht
auch eine intakte Natur eine intakte
Umwelt und ein intaktes Klima wir
brauchen fruchtbare Böden wir brauchen
einen gesunden Wasserhaushalt wir
brauchen Artenvielfalt bei den
Bestäubern oder kurz eine intakte Natur
nur damit können wir
Ernährungssicherheit weltweit sichern
und nur damit können wir auch den
Klimaschutz weltweit umsetzen und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir auch
eine ökologische Entwick Politik machen
meine Damen und Herren
die Bundesregierung hat viele gute
Schritte auf dem Weg gemacht zum
Beispiel indem wir unsere Mittel für die
globale naturschutzfinanzierung
verdoppeln auf 1,5 Milliarden pro Jahr
das ist ein wirklich gutes Zeichen und
auch guter Rückenwind für die
unbiodiversitätskonferenz im Dezember
frau Schulz ich bin Ihnen auch dankbar
dass sie den Schutzschirm gegen
klimarrisiken auf internationaler Ebene
vorantreiben und den
berichterstatterinnen und
Berichterstattern in den
Haushaltsberatung dass sie auch im
Bereich Menschenrechte und Umweltschutz
noch mal Akzente gesetzt haben das ist
ein gutes Zeichen meine Damen und Herren
eben Geld für Umwelt und Menschenrechte
brauchen wir aber auch ein echtes
Engagement für Fähre und gerechte
Lieferketten und jetzt sagen ja manche
wir haben es ja vorher auch wieder
gehört ja aber die Krise ja aber China
ich will meine Rückfrage stellen was
unterscheidet uns denn von den
dispotischen Regimen uns unterscheidet
doch dass wir Werte basiert
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit machen wollen
dass wir die Bedarfe der Partner ins
Zentrum stellen wollen der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit ein
Wettbewerb wäre es immer billiger kann
wer ist immer ruchloser kann den können
und den wollen wir auch nicht gewinnen
meine Damen und Herren
unser Merkmal muss sein wir stellen die
Menschenrechte in den Mittelpunkt und
das schätzen auch unsere Partnerländer
in der Welt denn für uns gilt eine
Ungerechtigkeit gegen einen Menschen ist
eine Ungerechtigkeit gegen alle Menschen
meine Damen und Herren und deswegen
müssen wir das lieferkettengesetz auch
nicht aussetzen sondern umsetzen und das
ambitioniert
und abschließend noch einen Satz zur
Union
sie haben ja hier wahnsinnig die Backen
aufgepustet was so diese Finanzplanung
angeht wenn ich in die Finanzplanung der
unionsgeführten Bundesregierung
reingucken dann steht dafür 2023 ein
Betrag von 9 Milliarden Euro fürs BMZ
wir stellen 12 Milliarden Euro zur
Verfügung 12 Milliarden Euro statt 9
Milliarden Euro unter einer
unionsgeführten Bundesregierung das ist
der Unterschied den diese
Regierungskoalition macht und gut dass
wir diesen Fehler die unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung korrigiert haben
herzlichen Dank
da gab es zwar viele Zwischenrufe aus
den Reihen der Unionsfraktion aber am
Rednerpult konnte hier Jan Niklas
gesenhues für die Bündnis Grünen noch
mal hier diesen Punkt setzen jetzt für
die FDP der nächste Redner blutgerschau
wird das sein
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag
der 8 milliardenste Mensch ist letzte
Woche geboren am Tag seiner Geburt wuchs
die Weltbevölkerung um durchschnittlich
180.000 Menschen das sind täglich
180.000 neue Möglichkeiten die Zukunft
zu gestalten besonders viele Menschen
werden in Afrika südlich der Sahara
geboren dort lebt die größte
jugend-generation aller Zeiten 43
Prozent der Bevölkerung sind jünger als
15 Jahren in diesen jungen Menschen
steckt ein riesiges Potenzial wenn sie
denn die Chance bekommen es zu entfalten
damit die Jugendlichen ihr Leben
verantwortungsvoll gestalten können
brauchen sie Gesundheit Bildung
Aufklärung und Selbstbestimmung denn
wenn sie aufgeklärt sind und meinen Job
haben entscheiden Sie sich in der Regel
für die Anzahl der Kinder die Sie
vorsorgen können auch deshalb bin ich
für eine Stärkung der Frauen von Frauen
und Mädchen und ihre Rechte wir brauchen
eine Verbesserung der reproduktiven und
sexuellen Rechte bessere
müttergesundheit und umfassende
Aufklärung
und das Thema
Bevölkerungsdynamik hat nicht mit
Bevormundung oder
neokoladenismus zu tun es ist der
Versuch negative
Konsequenzen für die betroffenen Länder
zu mindern ein weiteres wichtiges Thema
in diesem Zusammenhang ist die globale
Ernährungssicherheit der Haushalt macht
deutlich es ist nicht hinnehmbar dass
mehr als 800 Millionen Menschen auf der
Welt Hunger leiden deutlich mehr als
noch vor einigen Jahren leider können
wir den russischen Präsidenten nicht
daran hindern in verbrecherische Weise
Hunger als globale Waffe einzusetzen
aber wir können das entstandene Leid
lindern dazu stehen für das Welt
Ernährungsprogramm 50 Millionen Euro
mehr zur Verfügung als ursprünglich
geplant und für eine nachhaltige
Umstellung von agrar und
Ernährungssystem werden weitere 54
Millionen Euro bereitgestellt
umfassende
Gesundheitsvorsorge dies wird auch ein
beherrschendes Thema im Unterausschuss
globale Gesundheit sein dezentrale
medizinische Versorgung auch auf dem
Land Ausbildung von Ärzten und
Krankenschwestern Nutzung digitaler
Möglichkeiten in der Telemedizin
Entwicklung von Impfstoffen auch im
globalen Süden vor allem in Afrika Kampf
gegen Polio Malaria künftigen Epidemien
diese Themen werden wir auch in den
nächsten bundeshaushalten in den Blick
nehmen
zum Schluss weiß ich darauf hin dass
private Investments mehr als bisher an
Bedeutung erlangen müssen die
Privatwirtschaft kann durch ihr Know-how
und ihre finanziellen Mittel die Wirkung
staatlicher Hilfen enorm verstärken
Investitionen lohnen sich zum Beispiel
Energiebereich bei regenerativen
Energien und vor allem im
Zukunftsbereich Wasserstoff und wir
müssen junge Unternehmensgründungen mit
innovativen Ideen stärker unterstützen
denn das hilft eine mittelständische
wirtschaftliche Struktur in den Ländern
aufzubauen der Haushalt 2023 hat die
richtigen Weichen gestellt wie die
Kollegin Raphael schon eindrucksvoll
ausgeführt hat wir werden diesen Weg mit
Nachdruck weiterverfolgen vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
dr wolfgang stiefinger ist der nächste
Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja der
Haushaltsentwurf der Regierung war
wirklich schlecht das haben wir nicht
nur wir von der Union gesagt sondern
unisono in der Debatte auch die Redner
der regierungstragenden Fraktionen und
ich muss sagen der jetzt vorliegende
Regierungsentwurf ist gar nicht mal so
übel aber was ich ihnen nicht ersparen
kann ist dass ihr Italien schon zum
zweiten Mal in Folge sinkt und das ist
eben der Unterschied zu 16 Jahren Union
stetiger Anstieg des entwicklungsetats
12 Monate ampelkürzung und Rotstift
und auch die Finanzplanung für die
nächsten Jahre falls nichts Gutes Herr
gießen muss sie haben es mal wieder
angesprochen und ich muss hier wirklich
mit dieser mehr aufräumen dieser
Finanzplan kommt eben nicht von Gerd
Müller sondern von ihrem jetzigen
Kanzler der damals Finanzminister war
Olaf Scholz und sie regieren jetzt seit
über einem Jahr und haben diesen
Finanzplan nicht geändert der ist nicht
in Stein gemeißelt wieso ändern sie denn
diesen Finanzplan nicht
liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sind uns
einig dass es gerade in den heutigen
Krisenzeiten eine starke
Entwicklungspolitik braucht die Krisen
sind bekannt und diese gesamte Spirale
müssen wir auch durchbrechen und dafür
braucht es Sicherheit es braucht
Wachstum und es braucht auch neue
Entwicklungen und hierfür braucht es
eine Kooperation mit der Wirtschaft und
Frau Ministerin hier habe ich heute von
ihnen wieder nichts gehört und wenn ich
mir die letzten zwölf Monate anschaue
dann muss ich leider feststellen zum
Thema wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit
habe ich von ihnen bisher noch überhaupt
nichts gehört außer dass der
Haushaltstitel weiter gekürzt wird jetzt
weiß ich dass sie natürlich in der
Koalition sind und vor allem auch die
Grünen an der Backe haben die mit der
Wirtschaft der häufig fremdeln aber und
wir können es ja auch nachlesen im
Handelsblatt dieser Tage dass die
angeblichen wirtschaftspolitischen
vergessen der früheren Bundesregierung
fehlgeleitet waren ich kann Ihnen sagen
was die wirtschaftlichen Interessen der
letzten Bundesregierung in der
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit waren
das war Jobs schaffen Ausbildungsplätze
schaffen
firmenansiedeln und die deutsche
Wirtschaft bei Expansionsplänen in
Entwicklungsländer auch zu unterstützen
das waren die Ziele unserer
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit und sie
waren richtig
denn die Menschen brauchen Ausbildung
sie brauchen Aufstiegschancen und Jobs
und dafür braucht es eben mehr
Wirtschaft und weniger Schulkreis meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und weil
ich gerade auch bei den Grünen bin jetzt
ist er gerade die Klimakonferenz zu Ende
gegangen der Bundeskanzler war mit drei
Ministern vor Ort und er stellt sich
schon die Frage was hat diese
Bundesregierung da eigentlich erreicht
die Süddeutsche Zeitung die Süddeutsche
Zeitung schreibt weniger als nichts und
was haben sie gerade von den Grünen in
den letzten Jahren uns angegriffen uns
von der Union angegriffen und vollmundig
erklärt was sie alles umsetzen wenn sie
nur in der Regierung sind und was sie
dann in diesen Klimakonferenzen alles
machen ich kann ein paar Punkte nennen
sie wollten die Investitionen von
Industrieländern für erneuerbare
Energien verdoppeln haben sie in der
letzten Debatte dazu auch gesagt was es
vereinbart worden nichts dann die
Einhaltung da ist nationalen unser Ziel
ist Sie müssen verbindlich sein um sie
uns vorgeworfen was ist vereinbart
worden nichts sie wollten heraus aus der
kohlekopf 27 beschließt ja für Südafrika
und Indonesien eine Unterstützung um die
Abhängigkeit von Kohleverstromung zu
reduzieren das ist auch richtig aber
gleichzeitig kauft diese Bundesregierung
massiv Kohle aus Südafrika also ich will
mal sagen sie halten hier große Reden im
Entwicklungsbereich und auch zum Thema
Klimaschutz aber tatsächlich tun Sie
hierfür nichts Jürgen Retina hat in der
Debatte zu Kopf 26 der Union vorgeworfen
für uns sein Klimapolitik Pillepalle und
ausgerechnet sie kaufen nun die Kohle
aus Südafrika sie stimmen dem Zug
ausgerechnet ihr Minister macht einen
Hofknicks in Katar und gibt heute der
Nationalmannschaft klugschläge über die
Bild-Zeitung wie sie sich verhalten
sollen für uns von der Union ist
Klimaschutz nicht Pille sondern
wichtiger aber ihre Politik ist
scheinheilig und verlogen und Frau
Ministerin sie haben den klimavor
angesprochen das ist ein ganz
wichtigeres Instrument um Länder zu
unterstützen die vom Klimawandel
besonders betroffen sind aber am
wenigsten dazu beigetragen haben das ist
alles ein Heeres Ziel aber ich muss sie
fragen wie verbindlich ist denn dieser
Schutzschirm jetzt für die Klimafolgen
welche Länder zahlen denn hier wirklich
verbindlich ein wie verhält sich denn
China in dieser Frage wird China
weiterhin als Entwicklungsland
eingestuft das sind alles Fragen die sie
nicht beantworten die nicht geklärt sind
bleibt das alles so dann ist das kein
Schutzschirm sondern ein löchriger
Regenschirm und sonst gar nichts
liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen es geht am Ende ja nicht
darum bei einer hausarztdebatte welche
Haushaltstitel beim Tauziehen ziehen um
Steuergeld etwas mehr gewinnen das geht
darum dass Entwicklungspolitik kein
Feuerlöscher ist sondern
vorausschauend sein muss um
Lebensbedingungen für Millionen von
Menschen zu verändern und außer ein paar
wenige Themen habe ich von dieser
Bundesregierung noch keine Vision
vernommen sie arbeiten seit zwölf
Monaten an einer afrika-strategie ich
bekomme keine Auskunft bis wann die
vorgelegt sein soll von Ihrem Hause und
wenn ich mir die Debatten der
vergangenen Jahre anschaue mit ihren
insbesondere von den Grünen
wortgewaltigen Forderungen in dem
Bereich mit ihren Versprechungen wie
diese Regierung angetreten ist kann ich
nur eines immer wieder sagen nicht an
ihren Worten sondern an ihrem Taten
sollt ihr sie messen vielen Dank
Wolfgang stiefinger war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und den Klimaschäden
vor hatte angesprochen auf der
kopfvereinbart worden ist ja und die
Chinesen lehnen ist bislang ab darin
einzuzahlen die entwicklungsministerin
die hatte bereits darauf verwiesen dass
die Europäer durchaus die Frage
aufgeworfen haben bei der Klimakonferenz
wie lange China sich noch als
Entwicklungsland definieren kann
liebe Kolleginnen das Jahr 2022 neigt
sich dem Ende zu und wie das immer am
Jahresende so ist man
ja lässt die Ereignisse des vergangenen
Jahres Revue passieren und richtet den
Blick auf das was bevorsteht die letzten
Monate waren von zahlreichen Krisen
geprägt diese Krisen sind vielschichtig
international miteinander verwoben und
haben gravierende Folgen doch gerade in
Krisenzeiten lohnt es sich manchmal
positiv nach vorne zu blicken und eben
dran zu bleiben und das haben wir getan
denn nur so konnten wir sie erinnern
sich es wurde heute auch schon zahlreich
angesprochen ein deutlich niedrigeren
bmz-haushalt im ersten
regierungsentwurften eine Milliarde Euro
erhöhen
mit dem Haushalt legen wir essenzielle
Grundsteine für die politische Arbeit
des nächsten Jahres und ich freue mich
deshalb sehr dass der Etat für das BMZ
im Zuge der haushaltsverhandlung
aufgestockt werden konnte und möchte
allen dafür danken die daran beteiligt
waren
und wichtig ist zu sagen so bleiben wir
trotz der generellen Haushaltskürzung
für das Jahr 2023 bei einem ungefähren
Vorjahresniveau von 12,2 Milliarden und
das ist ein klarer Erfolg für die
internationale Gemeinschaft denn jeder
Euro der in der letzten Wochen
zusätzlich in diesem Haushalt
hineinverhandelt wurde trägt zur
Bekämpfung der globalen Krisen bei und
schafft eine nachhaltigere und gerechte
Lebensgrundlage für alle und jeder Euro
zählt ich konnte mich in den letzten
Monaten selbst davon überzeugen wie z.B
im Rahmen der entwicklungspolitischen
Zusammenarbeit in Bolivien der Zugang
dort wird der Zugang zu Trinkwasser und
der Abwasser entsorgen erheblich
verbessert und dies ermöglicht zwei
Millionen Bolivianer in den Zugang zu
besseren Trinkwasserversorgung und
leistet vor allem einen enormen Beitrag
zum Umweltschutz in einer so fragilen
und hier zeigt sich dass wir bereits mit
verhältnismäßig wenig Geld für die
Entwicklungspolitik viel erreichen
können klar ist aber auch und ich werde
nicht müde dass hier zu betonen wir
brauchen zukünftig eine langfristige
Sicherheit für das BMZ die jedes Jahr
wiederkehrende unklare Finanzierungslage
führt dazu dass die Entwicklungspolitik
oft in Form von kurzfristigen Projekten
handeln muss das wiederum widerspricht
ihrer Grundidee durch eine langfristige
präventive und partnerschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit nachhaltig Entwicklung
und Frieden zu fördern
um nachhaltige Entwicklung zu erzielen
brauchen wir langfristige
Planungssicherheit und denn nur so
können wir eben langfristig finanzierte
Entwicklungspolitik stärken wir stärken
weltweit die eng damit die
Ernährungssicherheit wir stärken die
wirtschaftliche und soziale Sicherheit
und wir stärken eben weltweit auch die
Rechte von Frauen denn eine langfristige
finanzielle
gesicherte Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
stärkt eben weltweit auch einen
menschliche Sicherheit und darum geht es
uns letztendlich
die meisten in diesem die meisten in
diesem Haus nicht alle aber die meisten
in diesem Haus wissen die Klimakrise
stellt für die menschliche Sicherheit
eben eine gravierende Gefahr da sie
erfordert daher auch ein weltweites
solidarisches Handeln ich bin Ministerin
Schulze sehr dankbar dafür dass sie sich
in den Verhandlungen um die
Weltklimakonferenzen in Ägypten mit
aller Kraft dafür eingesetzt hat dass
die Perspektive der Länder das globalen
Südens in den Mittelpunkt gestellt wurde
mit dem Staat des globalen Schutzschirms
gegen klimarrisiken wurde ein sehr
wichtiger Schritt erreicht hiermit
sollen eben diejenigen Länder und
Menschen finanziell gegen klimabedingte
Verluste und Schäden abgesichert werden
die besonders unter den Folgen des
Klimawandels leiden und ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass das kein lehrertopf
bleibt es ist daher ein klarer Erfolg
unserer Ministerin Svenja Schulze
und ich bin mir auch sicher dass
aufgrund der vierseitigen Erfahrungen im
BMZ im Bereich des Klinik
klimarrisikomanagement auch die deutsche
Beteiligung durch das BMZ gut verwaltet
wird
so liebe Kollegin ich komme zum Schluss
die der ich freue mich dass wir mit dem
bmz-haushalt die notwendigen
Konsequenzen aus den Ereignissen des
letzten Jahres gezogen haben und schaue
optimistisch auf das kommende Jahr in
dem wir weiterhin für eine
zukunftsorientierte nachhaltige
Entwicklungspolitik einstehen werden
Frau Kollegin vielen Dank
na gut
die Kollegin Deborah Döring hat jetzt
das Wort für Bündnis 90 die Grünen die
ist die entwicklungspolitische
Sprecherin der Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe und ich
bin ehrlich gesagt ein wenig verwundert
über ihre Worte nicht nur in den Debatte
sondern ehrlich gesagt auch der letzten
Wochen sie fordern hier lautstark das
eine aber haben im Haushaltsausschuss
und in den Anträgen im Ausschuss genau
das Gegenteil gemacht wenn ihnen die
Entwicklungspolitik und das glaube ich
Ihnen ja so wichtig ist und auch der
Kampf gegen Hunger den sie in den
letzten Wochen immer wieder betont hat
dann frage ich mich schon warum sie im
September im Haushaltsausschuss der
Freigabe von 70 Millionen Euro für die
Bekämpfung des Hungers in Somalia und
der Sahel Region nicht zugestimmt haben
die Begründung ihrer Kolleginnen dazu
war wir brauchen das Geld in Deutschland
wir halten also fest wenn es wirklich
darauf ankommt stellt sich die Union
eben nicht auf die Seite der Ärmsten der
Armen
und wissen Sie was Ihre Kolleginnen
außerdem noch im Haushaltsausschuss
abgelehnt haben ich sage es Ihnen die
Bereitstellung von 50 Millionen für
Kreditfonds in Osteuropa mit den
kleinere und mittlere Unternehmen aus
der Ukraine in den getreideproduktionen
unterstützt werden sollten dabei wollten
sie doch in ihren Anträgen zum Haushalt
im Ausschuss 73 Millionen Euro
zusätzlich für die Privatwirtschaft
ausgeben hier wollen Sie also am Schluss
die meisten Entwicklungsgelder
reinstecken in Initiativen von Konzernen
wie allianzbranche und die Deutsche Bank
und lieber Herr stefinger die mehrere
Studien zeigen dass durch die jetzige
Zusammenarbeit mit der Wirtschaft kaum
positive Effekte erreicht werden wenn
überhaupt erreichen diese nur
unmittelbar Beteiligte Partner und die
Zielgruppen das sind also Projekte die
eben keine breite oder langfristige
entwicklungspolitische Wirkung haben
das Märchen von der Hebelwirkung wird
offensichtlich noch geglaubt in ihrer
Fraktion und ich sage Ihnen statt mal
neue Lösungen zu präsentieren bleibt die
Union also wie gehabt bei der alten
Formel das haben wir schon immer so
gemacht und genauso machen wir weiter
aber so verhindert man die sogenannte
Entwicklung und zwar nachhaltig das
liebe Union ist keine präventive Politik
das ist Politik aus dem letzten
Jahrzehnt und ich bin froh dass wir als
Ampel das anders machen
wir machen eine feministische
Entwicklungspolitik
und ich höre schon dass in diesem Haus
ja immer noch einige Kolleginnen gibt
die noch nicht genau wissen was sie
darunter verstehen sollen möchte ich
Ihnen das jetzt anhand des Haushaltes
mal ein bisschen darlegen Ziel einer
feministischen Entwicklungspolitik ist
dass alle Menschen weltweit dieselben
Rechte und denselben Zugang zu
Ressourcen haben und den gleichen Maße
in ihrer Diversität repräsentiert sind
genau deswegen haben wir im
Haushaltsverfahren dafür gesorgt dass
der Beitrag Deutschlands für ihren
burmenstabil bleibt und wir mit dem
aufwuchs von UNFPA die sexuellen und
reproduktive Gesundheit stärken
eine feministische Entwicklungspolitik
bedeutet dass wir eben auch
Zivilgesellschaft als aktive
feministische Akteurinnen und Akteure
stärken
und genau deswegen haben wir als Ampel
die Mittel zu Förderung langfristiger
Vorhaben der Zivilgesellschaft und für
zivilen Friedens aufgestockt das ist der
richtige Weg um für Stabilität Resilienz
und Frieden zu sorgen und dabei die
Bedürfnisse von Frauen und
marginalisierten Gruppen zu
berücksichtigen
die Klimakrise es wurde heute schon
einige Male gesagt hat jetzt schon
verheerende Auswirkungen insbesondere im
globalen Süden die wir als globaler
Norden maßgeblich verursacht haben
dürren Unwetter steigende Meeresspiegel
und Frauen und Mädchen werden von der
Klimakrise besonders hart getroffen sie
sterben bei einer Katastrophe mit 14 Mal
höherer Wahrscheinlichkeit als Männer
weil sie beispielsweise seltener
schwimmen können oder sich auf der
Flucht um ihre Angehörigen kümmern
die Klimakrise bereits gefährdet bereits
Erreichte und auch eben zukünftige
Fortschritte und belastet insbesondere
vulnerable Gruppen weshalb gerade auch
hier feministische Ansätze wichtig sind
und lieber Herr stefinger da sie gerade
nachgefragt haben ja die Ampel hat
gezeigt dass Klimapolitik und gerade der
Schutz der vulnerabenden Gruppen uns
wichtig ist auf der Kopf 27 bei was sie
eben nicht geschafft haben ist das Thema
los und damage auf die Tagesordnung zu
setzen genau das haben wir gemacht für
Schäden und Verluste für den Klimawandel
für die ärmsten Länder eben was
beschlossen und
denn
denn auch die Stärkung in die
jenerrechte gehört zu einer
intersektionalen feministischen
Entwicklungspolitik in der überlappende
Ungleichheiten gemeinsam angegangen
werden das tun wir als Ampel mit diesem
Haushaltsentwurf
ja ich bin erleichtert dass wir als
Parlament in diesem Haushalt gezeigt
haben dass globale Gerechtigkeit für uns
wichtig ist
aber es gehört natürlich auch zu
Wahrheit dass wir alle wissen
strukturelle Änderungen brauchen
Planungssicherheit und langfristige
Finanzierung der bmz-kernetat muss in
den nächsten Jahren signifikant
ansteigen um langfristige Ziele
erreichen zu können und auch die Lösung
der rasant ansteigenden globalen
schuldenverschuldung müssen wir
ambitioniert entgegengehen und wir
wissen dass Sicherheit eben weit mehr
ist als militärische Sicherheit es
bedeutet auch Sicherheit vor Pandemien
sowie vor der Auswirkung der Klimakrise
Sicherheit ganz im Sinne einer
feministischen außen und
Entwicklungspolitik umfasst
Menschenrechte verantwortungsvolle
Regierungsführung Zugang zu Bildung
Gesundheit sowie die Gewährleistung dass
jeder Mensch die Freiheit und
Möglichkeiten hat sein Potenzial zu
entfalten lassen Sie uns gemeinsam dafür
kämpfen dass das auch in Zukunft möglich
ist mit unserer Hilfe wir nehmen unsere
globale Verantwortung ernst
ja mit diesen Worten von Deborah
Thüringen für die Grünen dann neigt sich
hier diese Beratung zum ETA
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung dem Ende zu genauso wie
dieser Tag der Haushaltsberatung zwei
Tage sind bereits geschafft zwei liegen
noch vor den Abgeordneten deswegen darf
ich noch kurz sagen und sie auf morgen
hinweisen da steht der größte Einzelplan
der für Arbeit und Soziales als
allererstes auf der Tagesordnung
deswegen sind wir natürlich ab 8:45 Uhr
wieder hier live aus dem Deutschen
Bundestag für sie dabei jetzt geht es
aber erstmal weiter mit den Kolleginnen
und Kollegen in Bonn und mit meiner
Kollegin Maja Weber